les arbres pour guérir la terre soit 100
prétentieux la terre ne va pas très bien
la terre c'est le dérèglement climatique
c'est l'effondrement de la biodiversité
et face à ça qui est très anxiogène
beaucoup s'en rendre compte de plus en
plus clairement
face à ça nous avons deux puissants amis
sur terre et ce sont les arbres est ce
que j'aimerais c'est vous montrer à quel
point les arbres sont puissants était
quelle manière nous devons nous associer
aux arbres pour mettre en oeuvre leur
puissance et comprendre leur mode de
fonctionnement pour travailler en
fonction de cette compréhension et ses
angles c'est des êtres qui sont
doublement enracinée ils sont racines et
dans la terre dans le ciel ils ont une
collection horizontale mais aussi une
connexion verticale avec beaucoup plus
que ce qu'on imagine et cette double
connexion ce double enracinement c'est
très important de bien le comprendre
à partir du moment où on considère qu'un
arbre c'est pas simplement un élément de
décoration c'est un organisme
et qu'est ce qu'un organisme voilà la
question qu'on va se poser
tout d'abord ces arbres c'est les autres
peut-être les plus impressionnants que
nous puissions rencontrer sur terre
c'est guy géant de l'espace et du temps
c'est des géants de l'espace plus de 100
mètres de haut
à l'époque on a abattu un mode un art de
132 mètres sans savoir que 136 mètres
sans savoir que c'était le plus haut les
arbres du monde c'est après coup qu'on a
réalisé sa et les herbes les plus
anciens c'est plusieurs millénaires
trois millénaires avant notre nos deux
millénaires que nous avons dans notre
période actuelle cinq mille ans et c'est
des arbres qui sont supposés pour être
finalement pratiquement immortel comment
font-ils cela quelle est la différence
entre un arbre et un tournesol le
tournesol lui chaque année il fait ses
feuilles satif ses fleurs ses graines
éparpiller les graines et tout repart à
zéro à l'automne le tournesol va
disparaître va retourner sous forme
d'humus les orbes font ça tout à fait
différemment quel est le secret des
arbres c'est un secret qui est visible
qui est vraiment à part en part tout
c'est sur chaque branche on a la réponse
à cette question
l'arbre ne fait pas chaque année le
retour à la terre avec ces graines il le
fait aussi une fois qu'il est devenu
adulte une fois qu'il est devenu fertile
mais avant pendant très longtemps il va
pousser très très lentement il va faire
beaucoup de racines une petite pousse
annuelle
hélas ne m'a pas chaque fois retourner
sur terre son embryon la graine est un
embryon mais il ya une autre forme dans
bryant c'est un embryon végétatif y
valeurs déposées
il va le former au bout de ses branches
formés chaque année sur le côté des
branches on appelle ça les bourgeons les
pour jean p ouvrir et découvrir qu'il ya
litige télescopique mans comprimé qui va
se déployer l'année suivante es16
l'arbre va pouvoir étage après étage
puisqu'il va développer sa ramure tout
son architecture avoir une colonie de
plantes en périphérie sortant des
bourgeons sortant des terres des de ces
graines placé sur une assise organique
et faire une enveloppe tout autour de
l'arbre tout d'abord purement végétales
et ensuite ce sera aussi des fleurs qui
vont ensuite être succès des suivis par
des feuilles ou inversément et ainsi là
on va faire une enveloppe qui se double
d'une enveloppe souterraine qu'on ne
voit pas où les racines aussi perdre une
partie d'elle-même à l'automne et
reforme des nouvelles une double
enveloppe visible et invisible
et cette notion d' enveloppe est très
importante pour bien comprendre un
organisme la biologie moderne
bruce lipton 2018 a réalisé l'importance
de l' enveloppe pour les organismes que
ce soit unicellulaires avec ou sans
noyau un pluricellulaires ou un être
humain ou un quelconque forme d'êtres
vivants d'éléments essentiels c'est pas
forcément le noyau éventuellement
certains organismes n'ont pas et son
vivant c'est l'enveloppé cellulaire et
c'est pas simplement une membrane qui
contient le cytoplasme la substance
vivante
c'est en fait une une structure qui va
permettre de réguler les flux d'entrée
et de sortie de substances de manière
josé décidé par lettre en question la
cellule où l'organisme il ya des
passages des petits canaux qui
permettent des flux entrants des flux
sortants de manière absolument calculer
et d'oser il ya aussi des protéines
inscrit dans cette enveloppe cellulaire
qui vont traversé il enveloppe qui ont
des sourds d'antenne ou de récepteurs
peau des signaux chimiques
électromagnétiques tactile chimiques ça
serait pour les odeurs acoustique aussi
et ses perceptions que ces protéines on
à l'extérieur dans l'ombre and de la
membrane cellulaire sont transcrites par
la cellule par la protéine à l'intérieur
de la particule en connexion avec le
cytoplasme en désordre pour le
cytoplasme pour que le cytoplasme sont
informés de ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur et c'est ainsi que bruce
lipton mentionne cette enveloppe
cellulaire comme étant le siège de
l'intelligence cellulaire on peut
vraiment comprendre pourquoi les
les êtres sont à considérer comme
intelligent quand on imagine tous est
énorme
durée 2 d'évolution qui l'ont prouvé
avoir traversé avec succès est une des
réponses de ses succès cette enveloppe
intelligente en fait nous mêmes nous
sommes pas construire autrement notre
enveloppe c'est la peau c'est aussi un
organe le plus important peut-être
l'organe tactile nous persuade la
réalité de d'un événement d'une présence
d'un objet tous les autres sont sujets
soumis éventuellement les illusions
parenthèse mais nos organes des sens les
yeux l'odorat le les muqueuses buccales
et c'est louis sont en fait des
développements de notre ectothermes au
brio de l'embryogenèse ils sont aussi
sortis de notre enveloppe c'est des
organes de notre enveloppe et la forêt
on a vu qu'elles forment son enveloppe
année après année elle est construite de
la même manière et on peut comprendre qu
un massif forestier naturel il constitue
une enveloppe il à la canopée
naturellement mais il se constitue une
protection périphérique qu'on appelle la
lisière forestière l'aurait forestière
la lisière forestière est extrêmement
dense extrêmement bien constituer
beaucoup plus d'espèces en lisière
confort est centrale et ainsi la forêt
protège son intérieur l'intérieur c'est
le sol forestier d'humus forestier qui
est très très important pour la forêt
qui capte le capteur d'eau on va le voir
plus tard encore et c'est une manière
pour la forêt de de protéger son trésor
le plus précieux c'est l'eau et ça va
lui permettre de faire de la biosynthèse
de faire de l'humus mais tout ça ça lieu
grâce à l'eau et cette notion de forêt
qui se constitue une enveloppe une
enveloppe vital on peut la considérer
sous un néologisme
las il vaut ce faire la sphère
forestière et grâce à ce cette
conception de la fois cette
compréhension de la forêt on va pouvoir
aborder notre terre notre belle terre
d'une autre manière d'une manière
extrêmement efficace
et d'une manière extrêmement conforme à
ce que veut la terre en tant
qu'organisme aussi l'intelligence de
membranes a été mentionné maintenant on
peut parler d'intelligence forestière on
a donc cette enveloppe forestière
surtout la bordure la lisière forestière
c'est un foisonnement d'espèces et qui
occupe cette lisières forestières
c'est des êtres céder les autres
végétaux naturellement des plantes
annuelles aussi mais c'est aussi des
êtres faisant partie de la faune c'est
des oiseaux des insectes des mammifères
cd curieusement des protéines des êtres
très riche en protéines et on peut
considérer ses habitants de l'envelope
forestière co-metteur des ambassadeurs
de la forêt qu'elle envoie à l'extérieur
et qui reviennent le renard par 3 km
revient le hérisson 250 mètres les
fourmis 50 m mais ils reviennent
toujours
les chauves-souris récolte des insectes
dans toute la périphérie et reviennent
dans leur arbre creux et ont des
déjections très très riches en phosphore
par exemple extrêmement concentré tout
ceci profite à la forêt elle envoie ses
organes et reviennent même les rivières
sur tandis forêt en leur poisson qui
descendent et qui remontent pour le
ferai ces grosses truites chargé de deux
qui vont pondre leurs oeufs
l'insémination aura lieu la toujours
dans les zones
les plus les plus petites de la rivière
les plus superficielles de la rivière et
c'est là-bas que ces poissons vont
mourir et vont laisser leur matière les
anguilles qui reviennent des sargasses
pour remonter dans ces forêts denses et
prairies reviennent avec un message de
là-bas la forêt communique avec beaucoup
plus que ce qu'on imagine voilà
l'intelligence forestière et voilà ce
qu'on a enlevé à la forêt lorsqu'on en a
fait des plantations aligné sans lisière
ouverte à tous les vents redonnant à la
forêt son intelligence c'est très simple
ça coûte peu mais c'est très efficace et
la forêt elle même c'est un organisme
mais c'est en même temps un organe d'un
autre organisme c'est l'organe de
protection finalement de la terre c'est
l'organe que la terre se met en place
leur poutre fois et est entièrement
couverte d'arbres l'amazonie également
et on peut comprendre maintenant que
cette ceinture équatoriale que la terre
s'est constitué au niveau de l'équateur
là où l'impact solaire est maximal
ici on a quelque chose qu'on a tout
récemment compris correctement on a un
organe de protection de la terre qui
transforme l'impact solaire qui est
extrêmement fort au niveau de l'équateur
plus fort que dans les déserts du sahara
par exemple et cet endroit de la terre
on croyait que les arbres poussent bien
parce qu'il est fait chaud et humide
maintenant on comprend que c'est
exactement le contraire s'il fait chaud
de toute façon il fait chaud et humide
aux tropiques c'est parce qu'ils y
pousse des arbres et simplement avec
cette phrase on revoit complètement
notre vision de l'amazone y par exemple
où on est en train de faire des trous
est dramatique et lassé des mélanges
aussi ses membres ne viennent pas on
peuplement pure on a vu là
l'image d'avant où c'est un mélange très
très colorés parfois dans les forêts
tropicales
lorsqu'en plantes les tilleuls tout seul
à la manière humaine on va pouvoir
constater un certain accroissement les
chaînes tout seul aussi mais si on
s'inspire de la nature qui elle mélange
les chaînes avec le tilleul aller dans
le parc de biologie en pologne près de
la biélorussie là bas c'est le mélange
championne chez nous aussi
c'est comme ça que ça marche d'après la
nature et lorsque les forestiers font
des plantations expérimentales en
mélangeant à dieu et se rendre compte
que le chêne pousse plus de 20% mieux
que s'il est tout seul lorsqu'il a
détaillé à la côté de lui avec le même
espace mots et les tilleuls pousse plus
de 30% mieux que lorsqu'il lorsqu'il a
des chaînes à côté de lui que lorsqu'il
est tout seul
voilà ce que la nature fait si des
complémentarités chimiques de systèmes
racinaires tout ça c'est à synergy
extrêmement efficace qui devrait nous
inspirer à nouveau et maintenant le
climat s'est rodé dioxyde de carbone
dans l'atmosphère
on a passé de 300 à 400 parts par
million même plus et maintenant les
arbres on a compris c'est la
photosynthèse sont capables de capturer
ce co2 y a pas besoin de jouer
ingénierie technique avec des aléas et
des impacts encore pire que ce qu'on a
jusqu'à maintenant les arbres font ce
travail depuis longtemps mettons les en
place pour capter ces cieux de avoir la
biomasse et réenrichir les sols
agricoles qui ont eu un appauvrissement
de leurs matières organiques alors
qu'ils étaient d'origine forestière on
les a complètement épuisé du point de
vue leurs matières organiques et les
arbres permettent de réintroduire cette
matière organique dans les sols et
d'autre part les armes ça ne produit pas
seulement la matière organique qu'on va
pouvoir utiliser comme quoi raméal
fragmenté ou compay hautes charges terra
preta des amazonien les indiens
d'amazonie excusez moi c'est aussi du
bois et construire avec du bois c'est
autre chose que construire avec m béton
métal acier c'est un bilan carbone qui
reprend du carbone au niveau de la terre
et qui déleste le
climat l'atmosphère de son effet de
serre alors que les autres un effet
uniquement d'augmenter l'effet de serre
voilà et ainsi on va pouvoir réfléchir
nos terres agricoles en mettant
suffisamment d'arbres elle s'était
repasle parce qu'ils ont perdu leurs
matières organiques qui est reparti sous
forme de co2 de l'info sur de nouveaux
devenir brune devenir presque noire des
terres-noires c'est fabuleux pour les
paysans elles vont sentir bon à nouveau
grâce aux arbres et asafa permettre
d'améliorer le bilan hydrique
on a vu pour la forêt l'essentiel c'est
l'eau pour l'agriculture ce n'est pas
différent
il faut savoir que la forêt n'est pas un
concurrent pour nous c'est un un
partenaire un acolyte qui alimente le
paysage en eau pour cent pour cent de
précipitations ici c'est peut-être
disons à m pour faire simple la forêt va
renvoyer 50 à 70% d'eau 50 à 70% d'eau
dans l'atmosphère faire des nuages et
des nouvelles pluies ou bien simplement
tempérer les environs et il va rester 30
à 50% dans le sol qui va diffuser
lentement pour alimenter les sources les
rivières c'est le cadeau que la forêt
fait aux paysages et c'est ça qui nous
intéresse c'est des paysages non
seulement boisé de la bonne dose mais
aussi alimenter en eau pour nos cultures
voilà alors qu'elle est fait pour
qu'elle et fort combien ce qu'il en faut
des expérimentations ont été faites sont
en cours des essais qui dure depuis plus
de 20 ans en particulier mais avec en
agroforesterie ça commence un peu plus
tard mais c'est très fort et on peut se
demander combien ce qu'il en faut et là
il ya une règle intéressante qui
pourrait intéresser les gens qui sont un
petit peu paresseux c'est la loi de
pareto commençant à remettre 20 % de
systèmes boisé d'individuels d où des
corps d'amboise et dans la
dans nos systèmes agricoles et nous
aurons 80 % de l'effet escompté
peut-être qu'il en faut même - peut-être
qu'ils en font un peu plus mais ça c'est
le non seulement un prix mais c'est la
perspective qui nous est donné voilà et
là on remet des oiseaux dans le paysage
et on sait maintenant que les oiseaux
active la croissance et pas seulement
pour défendre le territoire les chants
d'oiseaux et les stridulations
d'insectes font mieux pousser les
plantes et ça c'est absolument
intéressant et ça fait même mieux
pousser à se développer des mouches
et bien tout ça c'est exactement ça
c'est des fréquences vibratoire le mode
et vibratoires on est en train de
s'écouter et de se comprendre la nature
fonctionne de la même manière
voilà les prodiges qu' on était en train
de réaliser ça c'est des réalisations on
nous regret c'est l'agronomie du carbone
et le livre que vous voyez représenté
ici c'est ce qu'on sait déjà faire alors
mettons-nous à cette action sans oublier
une dimension la dimension cosmique des
arbres les arbres c'est des êtres qui
sont aussi reliées au cosmos nos
recherches ont montré statistiquement
scientifiquement qui a beaucoup plus de
connexions entre les arbres et le cosmos
que ce qu'on imaginait que ce qu'on
croyait comme étant une une superstition
est les grands projets de reboisement
qui vont avoir lieu bientôt vont pouvoir
profiter de ces savoirs des arbres
connectés horizontalement entre eux avec
leur intelligence mais aussi ses ordre
cosmique mans ancrée que ce soit au
niveau de la bioélectricité ou d'une
pulsation du fus des pulsations des
bourgeons et bien pour les grands
reboisement va devoir gérer des
pépinières des pépinières à très grande
échelle multiplient un peu partout et là
par exemple dans les pépinières on
pourra appliquer la chronobiologie
cosmique c'est à dire que le smi des
plantes des arbres varie en qualité en
efficacité en fonction de la des phases
de la lune
et là c'est un monde magnifique qui
souffre parce que ça nous oblige à
regarder au cosmos pour transformer la
terre grâce à nos amis des arbres qui
n'attendent que cela
merci
[Applaudissements]